hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
videos video heute ist zweigeteilt und
zwar mit ich erstens einmal über den
youtube wie frieden der derzeit ein
allgegenwärtig ist und zweitens wollte
ich auch einfach mal noch ein paar
fragen beantworten die mir bei twitter
stellen kombis auf youtube ist glaube
ich immer irgendwie am start also in
deutschland halt allgemein immer genau
dann können wir alle youtuber immer
korrekt miteinander leben in deutschland
muss allerdings jedes thema direkt an
die öffentlichkeit und hoch gepusht
werden scheint diese eigentlich von
allen youtuber sachen konflikten und
allgemeiner von vielen youtube entfernen
weil ich einmal auf youtube ein content
machen das merkte auch daran dass sich
beispielsweise eigentlich nie mit
anderen youtube kooperiere ich will
jetzt auch gar nicht über diese nicht
egal sache reden zwischenhändler auf
platt und dann oder dem erst kürzlich
aufgekommenen streit zwischen libyen und
der endstand ist durch den live stream
von simon es soll heute und die miguel
pablo und hier die sache gehen und ich
weiß das schon sehr viele leute was
zugesagt deswegen hier nur ganz kurz
meine meinung natürlich könnte man jetzt
sagen ey luca es betrifft dich gar nicht
aber es ist halt trotzdem youtube
deutschland und nicht in meinen trends
und jeder redet darüber meine videos
werden volkes per mit kommentaren was
ich dazu sage deswegen muss ich dazu
irgendwie was sache ist von bayern
münchen reden auch darüber wenn schalke
haushoch verlieren deswegen wir sind
irgendwie einer gewissen form eine
familie eine gemeinschaft und behandle
solche themen halt alle in dieser stelle
muss ich auch am ring dass ich überhaupt
keinen kontakt zur abscheidung zum media
pablo aber ich habe mir glaube ich
einmal auf einer hausparty gesehen aber
das war halt einfach so ich bin zu
meinen kollegen gegangen und er war
irgendwie auch auf dieser party und er
hat nicht von der seite an ich meine so
erkenne ich dann halt nur so richtig
nicht weil ich ihn halt da nicht kannte
das ist quasi der komplette wortwechsel
den ich je mit miguel pablo hat sie mit
ihrer zeit von irgendwas zu tun hab ich
glaube ich auch nie gesehen und noch nie
mit ihm geredet deswegen will ich das
ganze thema die auch nicht parteilich
angehen sondern wirklich einfach so
objektiv das ganze beurteilen
und dann ich sag mal was davon halte das
ganze fing damit an dass miguel pablo
einen disstrack wenn man das ganze dreck
nennen kann ich bin wirklich kein
experte aber das war echt unterste liga
also allein ein lied was zwei minuten
geht es einfach lächerlich und die räume
waren schlimm und ich fand's komplett
erholt er in diesem track irgendwas über
hier raus gesagt von wegen er wäre blöd
zu ihm und hat sich total blöd verhalten
und sei doch eigentlich sein bruder ist
jetzt irgendwie doch nicht mehr sein wo
ich hab euch die drei videos auf die ich
mich hier beziehen übrigens unten
verlinkt damit ihr euch das selber eine
meinung bilden können
daraufhin hatten hier ratschläge und 20
bis 30 minuten video hochgeladen wo der
irgendwie alles zusammengefasst und
sparen nachrichten gezeigt hat und
danach hat mir ihr partner und nochmal
reiz nun wieder hochgeladen gesagt hat
das ist alles irgendwie die stimme dann
hat sich irgendwas geredet und auch
sparraten gezeigt was er für
menschenalter ich will jetzt überhaupt
nicht die moralapostel spielen die sagen
dass man dies nicht in die
öffentlichkeit tragen sollte ich das
selber schon ein oder zweimal gemacht
habe aber miguel man man sollte keinen
beef anfangen wenn man so eine unfassbar
riesige angriffsfläche für kritiker
bietet ich sage euch mal was ich meine
macht den schlimmsten konnten den ich je
auf you tube gesehen habe ist mit jedem
trend mit benutzt die übelsten klick bay
titel es jetzt fake stores in dein video
bades in nahrungsmitteln pinkls auf
passanten hotelzimmer viele muss ich
eigentlich gar nicht mehr sagen kann ist
einfach wirklich nicht in worte fassen
wie selbst ein content verabscheue das
geht überhaupt nicht gegen mich als
person ich habe bisher irgendwie 236 mit
ihr geredet du kannst wirklich der
älteste mensch der welt sein das kann
ich überhaupt nicht beurteilen aber über
den content kann und darf ich urteile
nach dem finde ich einfach total
bescheuert also nicht wenig komplett
fehl am platz da ist dass das ist ich
weiß nicht was du denkst du was
hochzuladen an der stelle muss ich aber
trotzdem sagen ich feiert seine blogs
mehr oder weniger also ich finde diese
zusammengeschnittenen sachen die du
irgendwie auch mal was und wie du das
ganze zusammen schneidet mit dem buckel
habe ich so noch nicht in deutschland
gesehen das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
cool also ich bin jetzt nicht jemand der
dich komplett hated aber so ein paar
sachen verstehe ich einfach nicht du
sagst dir würde dich nur kopieren aber
du machst ihren youtube trend mitmacht
diese daten sammele klausel von anderen
youtuber die fußball challenge das hast
du auch nicht obwohl du glaubst jede
frisur von justin bieber das verstehe
ich einfach nicht ich mein ich sage
selber ich lasse mich inspirieren von
amerikanischen youtube an die marke
player oder polizei dass die bearbeitung
einer gaming videos angeht das heißt ich
würde noch nie gegen dem kumpel von mir
sagen hey du kapierst total mein gaming
style also das passt einfach nicht
natürlich habe ich das damals in einer
gewissen form einen brief mit logo auch
gemacht aber daraus habe ich halt
gelernt ich will doch gar nicht dass das
komplette video jetzt nur über diesen
tief geht bald eigene fragen beantworten
wollte aber das würde ich halt auch so
oft fragen wie ich da stellung beziehe
bei dem birk energie spätestens seit der
sache mit case fried auf den video dales
den youtuber kuchen tv und ich feiere
sein content eigentlich nicht als er hat
auch wieder gegen mich mal geheiratet
und so aber damit noch gar nicht
eingemischt
das kann er auch gerne machen aber der
angeblich ein sehr sehr gutes video
ausgehoben bezüglich dieser ganzen sache
natürlich war es wieder der typische
kuchen tv ziel also auf der einen seite
waren es triftige argumente die ja gut
mit zitaten und quellen
auseinandergenommen hat von mega flop
auf der anderen seite waren wirklich 50
prozent auf beleidigungen also aber ich
finde den standpunkt von sicher dass
klargemacht dass sie die beschreibung
verlinkt falls sie den kompletten lief
zusammen aber meine meinung zu der
ganzen sache ist jetzt ich will
überhaupt nicht beleidigend werden hier
gegen miguel pappel oder in ihrer teil
weil ich beide persönlich richtig
kennengelernt habe ich feiere euren
content beider leisten ich also ich
finde den von mir aber noch ein bisschen
schlechter als den von ihrer chars
einfach nicht wenn man praise macht wie
man beispielsweise mit seiner freundin
angeblich schoss macht also so crazy so
richtig an gefühle von leuten gehen
feiere ich überhaupt nicht wahllos auf
passanten pinkeln wenn man diese ganzen
verkehr benutzt fake stores erzählt und
einen irgendwie den style von anderen
leuten kopiert aber nicht an darüber
beschwert dass es anders ich feiere euch
beide eigentlich nicht in bezug auf
euren youtube kontert aber jetzt bezug
auf den streit will ich überhaupt keine
partei ergreifen also wenn ich mich für
eine seite entscheiden müsste will ich
glaube ich auf der seite von ihrer zeit
stehen einfach weil ich finde dass
miguel paris und wir sind die youtube
szene kaputt macht mit seinem content er
das ganze halt zu beginn in die
öffentlichkeit getragen hat über diesen
disstrack und ich meine hätte einfach
den kontakt abbrechen können aber
stattdessen kommt in zwei minuten trägt
ist nicht mehr in der kasse zerstörung
ist sondern halt wirklich zwei minuten
wenn rapper sich gegenseitig dessen geht
das meistens über 15 minuten aber jetzt
beantworte ich endlich mal fragen macht
mit komm ich meine friedrun julien wann
immer du willst mit 5 0 jetzt auf einer
skala von 1 bis 10 was ist deine
lieblingsfarbe im alphabet willst du
mich verarschen was würdest du tun mir
deine mutter sich im pizza verwandelt
willst du mich verrät faulheit ist die
letzte pizza der welt würdest du sie mit
seinen fans teilen oder alleine auf
essen freunde ihr wisst ich liebe euch
aber pizza ist einfach geil
wie geht es dir und wird demnächst ein
neues match kommen mir ist gerade ultra
gut ich habe gerade noch den kompletten
september uni ferien deswegen kann ich
jeden tag ausschlafen und mit höchstem
urge sache werde ich am meisten gefragt
em-zehnten zehnten kommen wahrscheinlich
schwarze kisten in denen
zusammen mit 1000 signierten stickern
also am 10.10.10 könnt ihr auf jeden
fall schwarze kiste stellen also quasi
die ist da hinten nur in schwarz mit dem
smiley und wahrscheinlich ich will dass
wir jetzt noch nicht allzu viel sagen
kommt am ersten zwölf wieder zum kreis
rottweil genau am ersten 12 2015 der
luca schock war sie online gegangen ist
so das erste mal deswegen jetzt gedacht
am ersten 12 2016 nämlich alle produkte
runter und war komplett neue produkte
rein dass wir so ein bisschen krasser
welcher komplett neue sachen reinen
fakten also beispielsweise longies oder
neue rudis und so einfach ein komplett
neuer stil aber auf jeden fall erstmal
zehn zu kommen schwarze kissen in den
luken am ersten zwölf wahrscheinlich ein
komplett neuer lounge band spielt mal
wieder blätter morgen
lasst mir leid da wenn ich morgen gott
sie meter hoch werden soll würdest du
nochmal zum thema rowland geht oder war
das eine einmalige aktion es kann keine
einmalige aktion gewesen sein weil ich
2015 auch schon da weiß ich war 2015 ein
sagt da jetzt dieses jahr drei tage und
ich werde definitiv lesens jahr wieder
drei tage da sein was ist dein lieblings
englischsprachiger youtuber werde ich
ebenfalls sehr häufig gefragt und
beantworte ich auch seit monaten gleich
casey leistet finde ich mache einfach
die besten blogs die es auf der welt
gibt ein paar deutsche blogger lassen
sich davon sehr stark inspirieren aber
katy heißt sein song weil es zwischen
see und land liegt gute überlegung hast
du schon fifa 17 gespielt und wie
gefällt ist die hat mir die demo
heruntergeladen und ich finde es ultra
geil also ich fand die ganzen übergänge
zwischen 14 15 und 15 auf 16 richtig
beschissen da kam nicht zu viel dazu da
waren ja so dass man überhaupt nicht
klar wie vor sind sie überzeugt mich
bisher kompletten das hatte ich noch nie
bei einem neuen fifa game deswegen bin
ich übelst auch fifa ultimate team und
auf den story modus also vielleicht
werde ich das sogar auf meinem channel
display wird es in einem shop noch
bettwäsche geben wir planen bettwäsche
wirklich seit monaten ununterbrochen wir
sind jetzt gerade dem prozess ankommen
dass das design steht und der stoff
weine ich es auch schon steht motto
freunde ich habe genau dort die cs
exemplare für die bettwäsche liegen also
da wurden wir drei stück zugesandt also
denkt nicht dass das so typische youtube
manager des prozesses von wegen jagd
einfach wegwischen
sondern wir wollen das schon was richtig
geiles machen und das noch mal zu
beweisen ich mache eigentlich nahezu gar
keinen gewinn an der bettwäsche
also ich will euch das einfach nur so
günstig wie möglich anbieten mit der
bestmöglichen qualität und es kommt
vielleicht auch am ersten 12 aber kann
ich noch nicht beurteilen stand
eigentlich die idee mit dem smiley als
markenzeichen dieses mal irgendwann mal
aufregend amerikanischen instagram seite
gesehen und von den ultra witzig habt
ihr immer so an freunde geschickt und
haben sich darüber auch immer amüsiert
beizeiten relativ witziger smiley ist
und dann habe ich den halt selber
nachgezeichnet ein bisschen abgeändert
ein bisschen hoch auflösender gemacht
und dann einfach als logo genommen und
das ist die komplette story warum snaps
immer wenn du auto fährst du kannst
deswegen schnell einen unfall bauen alle
leute die mir bei step folgen wissen
dass wahrscheinlich eigentlich immer
wenn ich irgendwelche lange sehr jungen
paares natürlich beim autofahren ich bin
ich der einzige ich glaube jeder
youtuber macht das irgendwie man muss
sich allein mal englisch und
amerikanische blogger angucken ihrer
wenn im auto sitzen haben die sogar ihre
fette dslr kamera an der hand und film
sich dabei wirklich ist autofahren
einfach mit zeit die enorm langweilig
ist meistens telefoniere ich mit welchen
geschäftspartnern oder uni kollegen wenn
ich einfach im auto sitze um die zeit
totzuschlagen aber häufig snap ich auch
einfach und wenn ich dann beispielsweise
drei stunden auto sitzen heute an zwei
snacks raus aber wirklich nicht solches
netz wie ich mit 240 irgendwie verlinken
spur fahre sondern wirklich werde somit
100 in der baustelle bin und weiß ok
links rechts kein auto und ich habe ihn
so eine wandhalterung für brandon handy
ihr wisst was ich meine und hab ich dann
mein navi mit meinen fingern bedienen
oder kurzen knopf als napster
draufhalten und quasi ins bett mache wie
der himmel schön aussieht muss ich im
hintergrund das ist egal und ich würde
mich jetzt auch als autofahrer
bezeichnen ich fahre derzeit noch 50 bis
60 tausend kilometer im jahr hat also
auch schon viel erfahrung und ich hatte
noch nie einen unfall oder irgendwas
anderes oder so toll toll toll dass es
auch nicht passieren mag ich weil ich
bin damit kein gutes vorbild und macht
es auch bitte nicht ist es echt
gefährlich aber es ist für mich als
filmemacher einfach ein perfektes
stilmittel
diese überbrückung zwischen snappy snaps
mit so einer autobahnfahrt zu schaffen
wenn ihr versteht was ich meine hast du
vor in zukunft mal wieder etwas mit
andere youtuber zu machen also die die
leute mit denen ich auf youtube was
machte sind ja max und seppel weil das
echt so wie ihr live kollegen von mir
sind aber mir hat einfach so jetzt
allein auf die letzte zeit gezeigtes
fame und dieses youtube den halt sehr
viele leute und freundschaften kaputt
macht und ich will mich einfach gar
nicht mehr auf solche leute einlassen
also es gibt viele leute die ich feiere
irgendwie juni in bern stefan gegen max
zettl rief alle die nach das sind alles
korrekte menschen wo ich wirklich sagen
okay mit ihm kann man sich super cool
unterhalt sowie falls jetzt irgendwie
vergessen habe aber ich mag euch
wirklich auch wenn ihr das seht ihr
wisst ihr das ja aber es gibt halt
wirklich viele leute denen man lieber
aus dem weg bleiben sollte was den
content angeht und das merkt ja selber
darüber habe ich auch am anfang geredet
das sind zwei kandidaten deswegen denke
ich eher dass ich nicht so viele
kooperationen in zukunft machen würde
dass das tier von dem video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen weil es getan hat lassen ich
habe die frage jetzt ein bisschen
schneller beantwortet euch gefallen ich
gehe sonst mal länger hoffen fragen
einen schrank immer wie es euch gefallen
hat ihr findet hier in smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren und hier findet
ihr irgendein anderes video eingeblendet
keine ahnung was ich da verlinken werde
weiß noch nicht genau was ist eure
meinung zu dem ihf derzeit auf youtube
was ist eure lieblings schreibt massiv
in die kommentare wenn ihr dieses video
bis zum ende jetzt geschaut habt ihr
seid die wahren zuschauer